[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
die vom sport hat katja stresow sehr
gern schon genannt am 31 tag des ukraine
kriegs gibt es keine spur von ernährung
dramatische lage in mario pohl
frankreich und weitere länder wollen
gemeinsam zivilisten aus der
eingekesselten stadt
beiden sagt polen unterstützung zu der
us-präsident betonte bei seinem besuch
nato länder zu verteidigen sei eine
heilige verpflichtung
und formel1 austragungsort in saudi
arabien unter beschuss obwohl in der
nähe eine rakete von rebellen einschlug
soll das rennen morgen starten die
gefechte in der ukraine gehen weiter
auch lemberg ist jetzt unter beschuss zu
einer ungewöhnlichen allianz haben sich
frankreich griechenland und die türkei
zusammengetan sie wollen alle in
sicherheit bringen die das eingekesselte
mario pohl verlassen wollen die einst
400.000 einwohner stadt wird seit wochen
von russischen truppen belagert
christoph distel und sarah laska
keiner zuckt mehr wenn der krieg dauert
zwischen den hochhäusern hier und da
gräber für die toten die lebenden machen
in den ruinen weiter besorgen wasser
kinder spielen eine frau erzählt wie
zufällig sich die schicksale von mario
pohl entscheiden
unser gebäude blieb wie durch ein wunder
stehen als die bomben fielen drumrum
brannte alles nieder in dem wohnhaus da
drüben starben 100 menschen es klappte
einfach zusammen und das war's
rund 26.000 menschen sollen es
inzwischen aus der eingekesselten stadt
heraus geschafft haben fast alle in
richtung sabrina bis dahin verläuft der
200 kilometer lange flucht korridor für
ihn riskiert mit erst am ziel auf
wir haben 15 russische checkpoints
gezählt alle möglichen menschen standen
da manche fast noch jungs die ernsthaft
glaubten sie würden uns befreien aber
auch ältere die in unseren taschen die
frauen unterwäsche durchwühlten
direkt südlich von sabrina beginnt
eigentlich besetztes gebiet darin auch
person jene großstadt die als erste fiel
diese bilder von russischer seite sollen
zeigen wie russischer soldaten die
gewonnene gegend von ukrainischen minen
säubern gleichzeitig aber melden us
verteidigungskreisen person wird wieder
gekämpft russland habe keine kontrolle
mehr über die stadt was ein schwerer
rückschlag wäre für den vormarsch
richtung odessa moskau weist das zurück
derweil zieht präsident selensky auf die
energieexporte seines feindes
zugeschaltet in doha drängt er die
golfstaaten mehr öl und gas zu fördern
hintergrund so könnte der westen
russische lieferungen leichter
boykottieren
russland muss verstehen dass kein land
energiereserven als waffe benutzen darf
um die welt zu erpressen
und noch ein beispiel für ukrainische
gegenwärtig die stadt in der auch das
personal wohnt dass die atom ruine von
tschernobyl überwacht
russische truppen haben slawo tisch
besetzt aber wie schon in versen halten
die einwohner mit friedlichem protest
den blau und gelb dagegen lassen sich
auch nicht von gewehrfeuer und
blendgranaten auseinandertreiben
mehr rauch am späten nachmittag dann
über lemberg ganz im westen zwei oder
drei raketen seien in einem tanklager
eingeschlagen heißt es von fünf
verletzten ist die rede wieder ist der
krieg auf 80km an polen und die
eu-grenze herangerückt
unser reporter jörg brase ist für uns in
der ukraine in der stadt greven etwa 200
kilometer nordöstlich von lemberg york
welche strategie verfolgt russland mit
diesen angriffen im westen der ukraine
also ich denke im westen geht es vor
allem darum das ukrainische militär zu
schwächen heute in lemberg wurde ein
öllager getroffen vorher bereits der
flughafen und eine militärbasis wir
haben lemberg heute morgen richtung
osten verlassen entlang der
belarussischen grenze in die provinzräte
wo einst der fünf ukrainische
atomkraftwerke liegt und dann weg
entlang überall kontrollpunkte
panzersperren sandsackbarrieren die wir
unter androhung hoher strafen nicht
reden durften das heißt man bereitet
sich zwar auf einen boden angriff vor
den mann aber nicht unmittelbar erwartet
auch nicht hier in der stadt riefen wo
ich gerade stehe auch hier gab es
luftangriffe bereits unter anderem auf
den fernsehturm aber wie gesagt es
wurden vor allem taktische ziele
attackiert und zum glück bisher noch
keine zivilen dankeschön für diese
einschätzung jörg brase live aus
grüttner
der us präsident ist seit gestern in
polen und nutzt seinen besuch für
deutliche worte putin dürfe nicht an der
macht bleiben sagte biden vor wenigen
minuten in warschau und er garantiert
sollte der russische präsident es wagen
ein nato-mitglied wie polen anzugreifen
dann werden alle 30 nato-mitglieder
beistand leisten aus warschau natürlich
stecker zum abschluss seines polen
besuchs eine kämpferische rede beiden
spricht über den freiheitskampf für die
demokratie über jahrzehnte die es auch
heute wieder zu verteidigen gelte
russland stranguliert die demokratie
nicht nur zu hause sondern will das auch
anderswo unter dem falschen vorwand der
ethnischen solidarität hat das
angrenzende nationen für ungültig
erklärt zuvor bilaterales treffen mit
polens staatspräsident
demonstrativer schulterschluss mit dutt
das polnisch amerikanische verhältnis
war kompliziert geworden duda großer
trumpf in beiden kritiker des justiz und
medien umbaus in polen jetzt in der
krise aber wie der annäherung polen ist
zum frontstaat geworden befürchtet
selbst ziel russische aggression zu
werden beiden sicher die nato
bündnistreue zu
wie sich das als heilige verpflichtung
artikel 5 darauf können sie sich
verlassen ihre freiheit ist unsere
wir wissen was der russische
imperialismus und viel wissen was ein
angriff durch die russische armee
bedeuten wir bedanken uns für ihre
außergewöhnliche führung
besuch bei ukrainischen flüchtlingen und
helfern kein land hat so viele menschen
aus dem nachbarland aufgenommen wie
polen biden will das würdigen und
geflohenen mut machen es waren zwei tage
die von polen aus stärke und
entschlossenheit zeigen sollen an der
nato ostflanke richtung moskau
unser usa-korrespondent m at wissen ist
mit in polen lassen sie uns noch mal auf
die rede des us-präsidenten schauen eine
wichtige engagierte rede was waren die
entscheidenden botschaften
ja ich glaube wir haben hier vor in
einen historischen paradigmenwechsel
miterlebt in der präsident hat die worte
ausgesprochen die in den letzten wochen
nicht ausgesprochen worden sind er hat
gesagt um gottes willen dieser man darf
nicht an der macht bleiben das heißt die
usa und die verbündeten sprechen offen
aus dass sie einen regime wechsel wollen
in russland das hatten sie bisher nicht
getan ich glaube der eindruck der
geschlossenheit der letzten tage hat
jetzt eben dazu geführt auch
entschlossen zu sein das man um die
freiheit kämpfen muss der präsident hat
wiederholt erinnert an die geschichte an
den kampf um die freiheit gegen die
deutschen aggressoren damals im zweiten
weltkrieg den kampf um die freiheit in
osteuropa gegen das sowjetregime zu
zeiten des kalten krieges und unter
diesem eindruck hat er eben aufgerufen
alles zu tun um den aggressor putin am
ende auch eine niederlage zuzufügen
das ist ein paradigmenwechsel ob die
geschlossenheit tatsächlich so bestehen
bleibt in den nächsten wochen das muss
man sehen danke für diese einschätzung m
at wissen war das live aus warschau
260.000 menschen sind mittlerweile vor
dem krieg aus der ukraine nach
deutschland geflohen überwiegend frauen
und kinder
doch auch hier sind sie nicht unbedingt
in sicherheit polizei und
hilfsorganisationen warnen vor
menschenhändlern und anderen kriminellen
die versuchen die notlage der
ankommenden auszunutzen so sander
santina hat mir
das sexuelle belästigung auch im
internet ein problem ist mussten die
gründerinnen des hilfsnetzwerk small
leidlich erfahren sie hatten auf
facebook eine wohnungsvermittlung für
ukrainische geflüchtete eingerichtet
nach der kontaktvermittlung bekam
ukrainerinnen solche nachrichten wenn du
single bist bist du hoffentlich küster
weil du musst mit mir im bett schlafen
vielleicht fast ich dich an dann jetzt
sofort eingegriffen haben die polizei
eingeschaltet strafanzeige gestellt und
haben diese frau geschützt bevor
irgendwas schlimmeres passiert ist
die geflüchteten frauen und kinder
schützen will auch karsten baumann von
der bahnhofsmission frankfurt er hat
seine mitarbeiter sensibilisiert und
warnungen angebracht bestimmte männer
hätten sich hier unter das publikum
gemischt das bleibt ob lose angeboten
wollen sie mal mit mir essen
nach der registrierung werden die
geflüchteten wenn nötig vorläufig in
einer sicheren sammelunterkunft
untergebracht maria floh mit ihrem sohn
über sexuelle belästigungen hatte sie im
internet gelesen
ich hatte das auch mit meinem mann und
meine familie besprochen ich passe sehr
auf meinen sohn oder auf mich ich möchte
auf keinen fall jetzt auch noch so etwas
erleben
die bundesinnenminister rinn ist
alarmiert dass frauen die jetzt aus
einer solchen katastrophe fliehen vor
ort jetzt auch noch solche furchtbaren
übergriffe erleiden müssen konkrete
zahlen in der ganzen breite liegen uns
noch nicht vor aber wir nehmen es
einfach sehr ernst deswegen wurden
mittlerweile in allen großen bahnhöfen
waren hinweise angebracht und die
bundespolizei verstärkt
wenn sie helfen möchten den geflüchteten
und den menschen in der ukraine dann
können sie das zum beispiel mit spenden
beim aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 auch heute sind
in deutschland erneut hunderte auf die
straßen gegangen um für den frieden in
der ukraine zu demonstrieren hier in
hamburg am jungfernstieg versammelten
sich rund 500 menschen zu einer
kundgebung unter dem motto frieden in
der ukraine sicherheit für europa in
köln wurden auf den platz vor dem dom
teddys aufgestellt symbolisch für die im
krieg getöteten kinder
jetzt zu corona wegen der hohen
infektionszahlen in deutschland rechnen
die kliniken wieder mit mehr patienten
auf den intensivstationen
die pandemie sei noch lange nicht vorbei
sagt der chef der
krankenhausgesellschaft gast dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland das
robert koch institut meldet rund
252.000 neuansteckungen binnen 24
stunden acht 1213 weniger als vor einer
woche
278 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidence
steigt leicht auf 1.700
58,4
in die
gescheiterte pkw maut wird wohl doch
teurer heute entschied ein
schiedsgericht das die vorgesehenen
betreiber anspruch auf schadenersatz
haben die höhe ist noch offen die beiden
firmen fordern rund 560 millionen euro
die pkw maut war ein prestigeprojekt der
csu 2009 10 hatte sie der europäische
gerichtshof als rechtswidrig gestoppt
morgen wird im saarland gewählt die
erste landtagswahl seit der
bundestagswahl und es zeichnet sich ein
machtwechsel ab bislang regiert
cdu-ministerpräsident tobias hans
gemeinsam mit den sozialdemokraten das
kleinste flächenland doch in den letzten
umfragen lag seine partei klar hinter
der spd und deren spitzenkandidatin anke
rehlinger in unserem wald studio in
saarbrücken es bettina schausten mithin
das wird ein spannender wahlabend morgen
nun ist eine wahl im kleinsten
flächenland deutschlands aber durchaus
eine mit signalwirkung denn hier wie
dann auch bei den nächsten wahlen im mai
stehen ja überall
cdu-ministerpräsidenten zur wahl
gemessen daran wundert es etwas dass die
neue cdu bundesspitze rund um friedrich
merz hier wenig geholfen hat tobias hans
der seinen amtsbonus hier nicht
ausspielen kann der wirkte ziemlich
allein auf weiter flur favoritin ist
ganz klar die herausforderin anke
rehlinger und es sieht so aus dass die
spd ein halbes jahr nach dem erfolg im
bund hier im saarland den wechsel
schafft die kleinen parteien angeln
allesamt an der fünf-prozent-hürde
wenn zwei von vier ist nicht in den
landtag schaffen könnte es sogar für
eine alleinregierung der spd reichen das
mal die ausgangslage beim auftakt ins
wahljahr 20 22 wir melden uns hier aus
dem zdf wahlstudio in saarbrücken morgen
ab 17 40 bis dahin danke für heute und
bis morgen dann bettina schausten
in afghanistan haben rund zwei dutzend
frauen für eine wiedereröffnung der
weiterführenden mädchenschulen
demonstriert mit plakaten versammelten
sie sich in der hauptstadt kabul und
forderten ihr recht auf bildung
die taliban hatten am mittwoch schulen
für mädchen ab der siebten klasse
geschlossen tausende schülerinnen wurden
an ihrem ersten schultag seit august
wieder nach hause geschickt die
entscheidung sorgte für scharfe kritik
westlicher staaten
die us band foo fighters trauert um
ihren schlagzeuger taylor hawkins starb
völlig überraschend im alter von 50
jahren er war mit der band auf
welttournee in kolumbiens hauptstadt
bogota wurde er tot in seinem
hotelzimmer gefunden die todesursache
ist noch unklar hawkins spielte seit 25
jahren bei den foo fighters und war als
schlagzeuger an einigen ihrer größten
hits beteiligt darunter all my life
[Musik]
jetzt zum formel 1 grand prix in saudi
arabien wo es gestern abend eine
explosion gab katia wenige kilometer von
der rennstrecke in jeddah entfernt
schlug eine rakete in eine ölanlage ein
abgefeuert von jemenitischen huzel
rebellen nach stundenlangen diskussionen
dann die entscheidung das rennen findet
trotzdem statt jetzt auch raketen auf
saudi arabien in jeddah wo die formel 1
rennwochenende hat gestern kurz nach 17
uhr ortszeit nur wenige kilometer von
der rennstrecke entfernt eine attacke
auf die ölanlage des formel1
hauptsponsors aramco nicht der erste
anschlag dieser art in saudi arabien bis
tief in die nacht zum samstag um 32 ring
alle parteien um eine entscheidung dann
sie wollen fahren
wir haben die volle zusicherung erhalten
dass für das land die sicherheit an
erster stelle steht nein nein egal in
welcher situation die sicherheit muss
gewährleistet sein
stillstand für die formel 1 scheint
unmöglich der umstrittenen deal geht
über zehn jahre saudi arabien 82
millionen euro pro jahr die anschläge
zielen auf die wirtschaftliche
infrastruktur nicht auf die zivile
bevölkerung und nicht auf die
rennstrecke ob sich rebellen in der zeit
einer instabilen welt auch daran halten
werden
ja und das qualifying für das rennen
morgen läuft momentan noch dabei hatte
mit schumacher in schweren unfall nach
angaben seines rennstalls war schumacher
nach dem crash aber immer bei
bewusstsein
er konnte das auto verlassen und
befindet sich aktuell im medical center
zur kontrolle zum fußball heute abend
erstes testspiel des jahres der
deutschen männer-nationalmannschaft es
geht live im zdf gegen israel jochen
breyer in sinsheim unter welches motto
stellt bundestrainer pflegt dieses spiel
heute abend
ja das motto lautet wm kader casting es
sind ja nur noch acht spiele bis zur
weltmeisterschaft in katar und es fehlen
heute einige stammkräfte wie kimmig
goretzka oder reus das heißt viele
spieler aus der zweiten reihe haben
heute die chance sich dem bundestrainer
zu zeigen sich zu empfehlen und das
zweite motto lautet sicher die
begeisterung aus den letzten spielen
mitzunehmen seit hansi flick übernommen
hat sieben spiele sieben siege und diese
aufbruchstimmung die soll natürlich
möglichst halten dieses ganze jahr über
bis nach katar also vielleicht das
nächste tor festival heute abend wir
melden uns um 20.15 hier aus sinsheim
dankeschön jochen ja und noch dies
wieder ohne podestplatz blieben
deutschlands skispringer beim
saisonabschluss in planica slowenien im
mannschaftswettbewerb überzeugten karl
geiger und andreas bellinger zwar von
der flugschanze markus eisenbichler
constantin schmid aber blieben hinter
den erwartungen zurück am ende rang fünf
für deutschland sieger wieder mal das
team aus slowenien
morgen letztes einzuspringen dann ist
der winter aber wirklich vorbei und die
slowenen rumlaufen die haben im lauf
dankeschön katja draußen war es heute
herrlich strahlend blauer himmel und
temperaturen bis zu 22 grad zum beispiel
in stuttgart wer konnte der genoss die
sonne und dem frühsommer in vollen zügen
apropos sommer heute nacht werden die
uhren auf sommerzeit umgestellt heißt
eine stunde vor von zwei auf drei und
auch morgen wird es für die meisten
sonne ich auch wenn sich anfangs
dichtere wolken zeigen details hat
gleich katja hanf christian sievers
begrüßt sie in der halbzeitpause um halb
zehn im heute journal
wer sein jazz und freuen sie freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind einen
schönen abend wünschen
[Musik]
guten abend da ist tatsächlich dieses
wolkenband herangekommen die kleine
kaltfront wie für ein bisschen regen
immerhin sorgte diese kaltfront wird
aber morgen weiter nach süden und
südosten ziehen und dabei immer mehr
zerfleddern heute nacht sagt sie
allerdings dafür dass unter den
dichteren wolken hier in der mitte die
temperaturen mild bleiben mit 8 bis 5
grad im nordosten bildet sich nebel bei
minus zwei grad und frostig wird auch im
süden morgen vormittag gibt's noch
dichtere wolken besonders so zwischen
sauerland und sachsen und auch hier im
norden ist es zunächst trüb das ändert
sich dann am nachmittag dann kommt auch
dort häufiger die sonne zum vorschein
im süden ist es sonnig da kann sich mal
eine quellwolken bilden der wind kommt
aus südwestlichen bis nordwestlichen
richtungen und an der nordsee bleibt es
daher bei 12 bis 13 grad am kühlsten in
süddeutschland klettern die werte
dagegen nochmal auf 18 bis 22 grad das
aber wird sich ändern die temperaturen
stürzten in der kommenden woche
regelrecht ab am donnerstag sind es nur
noch sechs bis zwölf grad es wird also
deutlich wolkiger und wechselhafte der
dringend benötigte regen scheint aber
keineswegs überall guten abend